ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูนิคสวัสดีครับผู้หญิง
สวัสดีน่ะสิค่ะ
รูนิคจองได้
แล้ว
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
ผู้หญิงสบายดีไหมสบายดีค่ะครูนี้ล่ะคะ
สบายดีนะคะเด็กสบายดีครับค่ะแกเออตอนนี้
ตอนนี้ที่ประเทศไทยที่คุยหญิงอยู่อากาศ
เป็นยังไงครับ
ตอนนี้เลยใช่ไหมคะตอนนี้เนี่ยที่อันนี้
Condominium ใช่ไหม Condominium ผู้หญิง
ตอนนี้เนี่ยฝนตกหนักมากโขเพราะว่าจะเป็น
สีฟ้าเลยใช่ไหม
ฝนตกคะแล้วก็ลมแรงมากค่ะหลบแลนแบบฮือโอเค
แล้วแล้วที่บ้านครูนิคเป็นยังไงคะตอนนี้
ตอนอากาศ Love ก็
อากาศอากาศอากาศเย็นครับเอ่อมีลมแรง
ครับชายอารมณ์เหมือนกันชายมีลมเหมือนกัน
เริ่ม
แอบฝนยังไม่ตกค่ะกลับคิดว่าเดี๋ยวคงอีก
สักประมาณ 1-2 ชั่วโมงครับเออ
ใส่
ท้องฟ้าสีสีเทาแล้วตอนนี้นะตอนนี้เนี่ย
ท้องฟ้าที่ที่บ้านครูบิ๊กนะคะไม่ได้เป็น
สีฟ้านะคะเป็นสีเทาสีเทา
นะครับ
เห็นสีเทานี้ก็คิดเองมาแล้วฝนกำลังจะตก
หรือเปล่า
ที่ด้วยเหอะออกไปข้างนอกไม่ได้ละ
ใช่ค่ะก็จริงๆที่กรุงเทพฯก็ดีนะคะเพราะ
ว่าตอนนี้เนี่ยที่กรุงเทพเนี่ย 20:00 น
ประมาณปุ๋ย
20:00 น
โอเคสร้างผลเนี่ยฝนแน่ตกตอน 8:00 นก็ดี
เพราะว่าทุกคนเนี่ยขับรถกลับบ้านแล้ว
ขับรถกลับบ้านแล้วก็อยู่บ้านกินข้าวดู
ทีวีเตรียมตัวจะนอน
ศีรษะศุภชัยหักเรียนตัวจะนอน
คุยกับเราคิดครูนิคจะให้นอนตั้งแต่ 20:00
นเลยเหรอคะเล่นไงเด็กดีนอน 2 หมอ
วัดข่อยที่เราเป็นเด็กไม่ดีไปแล้วเนาะว่า
แบบถ้าถ้าฝนมันตกอ่ะแล้วก็
ฝนตกใช่ไหมคะอ่าคือขับรถเนี่ยก็ไม่โอเค
หรือว่าถ้านั่งรถไฟฟ้าน้องกรุงเทพฯเขาจะ
มี
รถไฟฟ้านะคะ BTS ครับ
[เพลง]
โรงเรียนเข้าใจไหมคะนี่รถไฟฟ้า
โอเค
ฉัน
รถไฟฟ้านะคะ BTS นะคะไม่ใช่นักร้องไม่ใช่
นักร้องเกาหลีและอันนี้เป็นรถไฟฟ้าชี S
เรานั่งไปในกรุงเทพฯไป Siam ไปได้โชว์ชาย
ไปมุมศาลาแดง
ฉายค่ะว่ารถไฟฟ้าเนี่ยเร็วแล้วก็เวลาที่
ฝนตกก็ยังโอเคก็เร็วพี่ชาย
ทรายแต่ว่ารถฝนตกมันจะช้าไหนพอรถไฟฟ้า
เดี๋ยวมันจะอยู่ข้างบนนะคะนั้นแหละมันจะ
รออยู่เลยแล้วก็ข้างล่างเนี่ยรถ
ถ้าเราขับรถรถจะอยู่ถนนอยู่ข้างล่างรถไฟ
ฟ้าจะอยู่ข้างบน
แต่ว่าเวลาฝนตกคนก็รอรถไฟฟ้าเยอะนะคะใช่
เดี๋ยวก่อนหญิงเราลืมเราลืมบอกวันที่หรือ
เปล่า
เขาต้องจะไม่ทันแล้วมั้ย
อะเดี๋ยว
เดี๋ยวก่อนเดี๋ยวก่อนเข้าเรื่องเดิมก่อน
เข้าเรื่องคนเยอะรถไฟฟ้าเรามาคุยวันที่ก็
ได้อ้ะได้ขึ้นในโลกนะคะนี่ไงที่จะหวานไหว
นะ
คนไก่เริ่มก่อนวันนี้วันอะไรครับผู้หญิง
วันนี้วันพุธฉากทูนิคสเมื่อวันที่เท่า
ไหร่ครับวันที่ 25 โอเคเดือนอะไรครับ
เดือน
พฤษภาคมค่ะปีพตอะไรครับปีพ.ศ
แล้วปีคศอะไรครับปีคศ 2000  22 ค่ะโอเค
โอเคก็ก็เมื่อกี้เรารู้แล้วนะว่าตอนนี้
ที่ไทย 20:00 นใช่ไหมถ่าย 20:00 นแต่ว่า
ที่อเมริกาตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้
เที่ยวอเมริกาครับเวลา
8:00 นตอนนี้ 8 โมง 9 นาทีละตอนเช้า
น้ำ 08:00 นจริงๆถ้าเป็นของครูนิค 8:00 น
ตอนเช้าก็ต้องอาจจะเตรียมตัวไปทำงานไหมจะ
ไปทำงาน
แต่ครับ
คุณนี้ก็คงไม่ได้นั่งรถไฟฟ้าไปทำงานไม่
เพราะบ้านแถวบ้านโคนิคตอนนี้เนี่ยมันบ้าน
คนเล็กมันอยู่เหมือนนอกเมืองมันจะไม่มี
อะไรปรึกษาต้องขับรถ
หิวข้าวใต้แต่ว่ากรุงเทพฯกรุงเทพฯเป็น
เมืองน้องมีแบบนี้คอนโดมิเนียม e-office
มีอพาร์ทเม้นท์มีตึกใช่ไหมคะพี่ตึกสูงๆ
อย่างเงี้ย
มากๆน้องถ้าขับรถก็ไม่ใช่ทุกคนจะมีรถ
กรุงเทพก็จะมีรถไฟฟ้านะรถไฟฟ้าให้คน
กรุงเทพฯไซส์ถ้าแบบรีบใช่ไหมคะมีเวลาน้อย
และแบบรีบมากๆนั่งรถไฟฟ้าท่ายิงแบบเหมือน
ผู้หญิงบอกใช่ไหมคะว่า
ก็ต้องเวลาที่
กรุงเทพเนี่ยฝนตกข้าวฝนตกแบบตกหนักๆอย่าง
เนี้ยค่ะทุกคนก็อยากจะกลับบ้านถ้าแบบตก
ประมาณสัก 18:00 นคิดว่าไม่เห็นนะคะ
18:00 นเห็นแล้ว
07:00 นถึง 18:00 น 19:00 นถ้าฝนตกกับ
เป็นเวลาเลิกงานเนาะให้เราคนก็เยอะใช่คุณ
ก็เยอะมากอย่างครูนิคเนี่ยเคยรอรถไฟฟ้า
ที่สถานีสยามไหมคะครอบเคยครับเคยตอนสมัย
เรียนที่มาหาวิทยาลัยนะก็นั่งรถไฟฟ้าตลอด
ชายนี่บ้านไปมหาวิทยาลัย
ทรายก็สถานีสยามเนี่ยก็จะเป็นสถานีที่
ใหญ่เนาะมันจะมีแบบ 2 ขอฝันนะคะนักเรียน
อันนี้ทั้งบทนี้ก็มีรถไฟฟ้าเหมือนกันค่ะ
ที่สถานีสยาม
ขอโทษค่ะมันจะต้องไปกันคนละทาง
อ๋อมันไปทางเดียวมันทางเดียวกันได้ 4
เพราะว่าไปแบบซ้ายขวาใช่ไหมเออใช่ๆกว่าไป
ทางเดียวกันนะขอบคุณค่ะ
ตัวมันก็จะมีเป็นสถานีกลางใช่ไหมคะถ้าครู
นิคเนี่ยมาจากสุขุมวิทแล้วจะเปลี่ยนไป
สีลมก็ต้องเปลี่ยนที่สยามเวลาสถานีสยาม
เนี่ยช่วงประมาณแบบเลิกงานคนเนี่ยเลิกงาน
เด็กๆเนี่ยเลิกเรียนเรียนเสร็จจะกลับบ้าน
ก็คนแน่นมากไม่ใช่คนเยอะอย่างเดียวนะคะคน
ที่แบบคนเยอะถ้า
ไม่มีที่คนที่ยืน
ใช่ค่ะอันนี้ก็จะออกใช่ไหมอันนี้อะไรก็จะ
เป็นทางเข้าเข้า
สายทุกคนเนี่ยยืนรอยืนรอ BTS
คนคนคนคนคนคนคน
ๆเยอะมาก
เยอะมากชายค่ะทุกคนก็รีบใช่มั้ยอยากจะ
กลับบ้านผู้หญิงเนี่ยเมื่อก่อนทำงานที่
ออฟฟิศเนี่ยถ้าจะกลับบ้านก็ต้องมาขึ้นรถ
ไฟฟ้าที่สยามก็กินเดินมาเดินจากออฟฟิศนะ
คะแล้วก็มา Siam ขึ้นรถกลับบ้านขึ้น
บีทีเอสกลับบ้านถ้าฝนตกเราก็ไม่นั่ง
แท็กซี่เนาะไม่แท็กซี่ถ้าฝนตกนั่งแท็กซี่
นี่ไม่ต้องพูดเลยคือแฮะ
หมอก็ไม่ไปเนาะเออแท็กซี่ก็ไม่ไปใช่ที่
ไทยนี่ก็แปลก
จริงครั้ง
ที่ไหนเพราะว่าคุณคืนนี้คิดว่ามีแค่ใน
ประเทศไทยนั่นแหละเวลาเราจะขึ้นแท็กซี่นะ
ต้องถามว่าไปไหม
ที่นี่ไม่มีนะที่นี่คือขึ้นไปแล้วค่อยบอก
เขาว่าจะไปที่นี่เราคือเหมือนต่างประเทศ
ที่ไม่ใช่ในประเทศไทยเนี่ย
ถ้าเป็นพวกประเทศอ่ะตามประเทศที่ไม่ใช่ใน
เอเชียดีกว่าถ้าเราต้องขึ้นรถแท็กซี่แล้ว
บอกเขาเลยว่าจะไปที่นี่แล้วเขาต้องไปกับ
เรา 3 คือคือเขาบอกว่าไม่ไปไม่ได้ได้ไม่
ได้เหมือนเขาจะทำผิดถ้าเขาบอกว่าเขาไม่ไป
นะ
ใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าคนไทยเนี่ยคนไทยเวลาเรียก
แท็กซี่ๆแล้วคนไทยเรียกแท็กซี่ในกรุงเทพฯ
หรืออาจจะที่อื่นด้วยก็ได้อ่ะค่ะเพราะว่า
มันคนเราไม่รู้ว่าประเทศอื่นเหมือนประเทศ
ไทยไหมเวลาคนไทยเรียกแท็กซี่เปิดแล้ว
แท็กซี่และขับมาแล้วก็จอดเราก็จะเปิด
ประตูแล้วก็ถามว่าไป Siam ไปไหมคะ
ใช่ช่วยถ้าค่าแท็กซี่บอกไปเราก็ค่อยขึ้น
รถทรายแต่ขอบคุณอีกพูดอ่ะผู้หญิงก็จำได้
ว่าเคยเห็นคนต่างชาติที่ไม่ใช่คนไทยขอเขา
เรียกแท็กซี่แท็กซี่ขับมาแล้วก็จอดแล้ว
เขาก็เปิดประตูแท็กซี่ก็เข้าไปนั่งแล้วก็
ปิดประตู
ซักประมาณ 3 นาทีเวลาผ่านไปก็ประมาณนี้
แหละประมาณ 3 นาที
แท็กซี่ก็ยังจอดอยู่นะคะคนต่างชาติก็เปิด
ประตูแล้วก็แล้วเนี่ย
ใช่เพราะมันไม่เหมือนกันมันไม่เหมือนกัน
ที่ต่างประเทศจัดที่นี่เดี๋ยวแป๊บนึงนะ
ครับเดี๋ยวคุณมิกพอร์ซ
เลนซี่น้องเพราะว่าคนต่างชาติเนี่ยบาง
ครั้งเขาไม่เข้าใจรถไฟฟ้า BTS เขาก็คิด
ว่าแท็กซี่เดี๋ยวมันสะดวกกว่า
ใช่ไม่แพงนะไม่แพงสำหรับคนต่างชาติไม่แพง
ใช่พูดถึงแท็กซี่อะครับถ้าคุณอีกจะไม่ผิด
อ่ะที่สยามห้างสยามพารากอนนะก็คิวยาวก็
เขามีจุดที่รับเธอเบอร์จุดที่แท็กซี่เข้า
มารับคนแล้วก็จะมีเจ้าหน้าที่มีคนต่อแถว
ยาวเหมือนกันเวลา
18:00 นหรือ 19:00 นใช่เป็น
รอดูรอแท็กซี่ใช่ไหมคะคิวรอแท็กซี่ก็ต่อ
แถวยาวกันเลยว่าถ้าใส่ตรงหลีเนี่ยแล้วก็
ตรงนี้ก็เป็นสยามพารากอนอ่าอันนี้
สยามพาราก้อนนะคะ
คุณนี้เคยไปต่อคิวแถวนั้นหรอคะนี้แท็กซี่
คู่นี้เคยกูนี่เคย
แต่คนนี้ก็ยืนรอแป๊ปเดียวเราคู่เนี่ยก็
ไม่รอแล้วเขาจะมาคุณมางานกว่าจะถึงคิวเรา
นะกว่าจะถึงคิ้วเรียกเราบางทีก็คุณนี้กะ
เคยเจอว่าบางทีจะมี
คุณนิคจะไม่บอกว่าเป็นคนที่ไหนนะแต่ไม่
ใช่คนไทยเข้าข้อ 5 ๆมัดแซงคิว
เหมือนคุณนิยืนรอคิวอยู่ตรงนี้ใช่ไหมคะ
แล้วก็เขาก็จะมีคิวเนาะไม่รู้ใครนะคะเป็น
คิวใช่นี้คุณนิคแล้วเขาก็มาจากไหนก็ไม่
รู้แล้วก็มาที่อาเภอแซงเข้ามาเลย
ใช่เออเราก็แบบให้ทีนี้ทวีปไงอ่ะคนดีกว่า
มันไม่นอกไหมก็สะกิดนะสะกิดเพราะว่า
สระเกศบอกเขาว่าเฮ้ยมันเนี่ยมีคนรออยู่ทำ
อย่างนี้ไม่ได้ต้องฝากต่อท้ายแถวท้ายคิว
แล้วอุ้ยเขาไปไหมคะเขาก็เขาก็ไม่ไป
ใช่เพราะว่าเขาไม่เข้าใจ
แล้วเขาก็ไม่สนใจที่คุณนิกพูดใช่ไม่สนใจ
คุณนี้ก็เลยแบบเออเพราะว่าคนอื่นก็มองแต่
ก็ไม่ช่วย
ไม่ปูใช่ไหมแบบวันนี้ก็นี้คนนี้ก็
คิดเฉยๆทำไมแซงคิวเออแล้วก็เป็นไทย mon
mon
หมอดูเว้ยมีอะไรตรงนั้นจะเออ S ทำอะไรกัน
ไปทำไมมีคนพูดๆได้ยินนะช่วยพูดนะ
จริงๆนะเพราะว่าผู้หญิงก็เป็นค่ะคุณนิค
แบบเวลาที่เราเนี่ยรอคิวอยู่แล้วมีแบบมี
คนจะมาแซงคิวเราผู้หญิงก็ไม่พูดเออ
เหมือนสมุดว่าเราแบบซื้อของหรือว่ารอรถ
อะไรอย่างเงี้ยอ่ะแบบมีทางเข้าอย่างนี้
ใช่มั้ยอย่างถ้าเป็น BTS
น่ะก็ไม่ใช่คุณว่าผิดตรงนี้มันต้องออกนะ
คะคนจะออกจากบีทีเอสแล้วก็ตรงนี้เข้าได้
สองแถว
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยเคยยืนรอคิวอยู่นี่ก็มีคิว EQ
คือคิวมันยาวมากๆค่ะทุกคนอยากไปแล้วพอดี
ถ้าวันนี้ผู้หญิงนะปิ่งเอาไปสีเขียวและ
กันเนี่ยผู้หญิงเนี่ยยืนรอคิวอยู่แล้วก็
มีผู้หญิง 1 คนก็ไม่ใช่คนไทยเหมือนกันนะ
คะเป็นคนประเทศหนึ่งเนี่ยเขาก็จริงๆเขา
อยู่ตรงนี้นะคะคุณนี้เธออยู่ตรงนี้แล้วก็
เป็นผู้หญิงเนาะอันนี้ก็เหมือนกับคนนี้
น่าจะอายุประมาณ
60 อ่ะแล้วเขาก็มีลูกสาวลูกสาวเนี่ยก็
น่าจะอายุแบบ 30 ประมาณ
ประมาณนะคะซึ่งเวลาเรารอแล้วบีทีเอสมา
เนี่ยประตูประตู BTS เนี่ยมันจะเปิดตรง
นี้ประตูเปิดคนที่อยู่แถวตรงนี้เนี่ยจะ
ได้เข้าก่อนเถิดเพราะอยู่ใกล้มันเนาะ
เพราะมันอยู่ใกล้อ่ะคือคนที่อยู่แถวนี้
กับแถวนี้อาจจะต้องรอนานทำไมคะผู้หญิงคน
นี้ค่ะเขาก็ไม่เข้าแถวไม่เข้าคิวโอเคค่ะ
จะเดินเดินๆ
มามาอยู่ใกล้ๆกับครูหญิงข่าวเขาก็เดินมา
อีกแล้วแบบกระแสคิวฉันหรอจะแซงคิวฉันใช่
ไหมจะแซงคิวหรือเปล่าคิดให้คิดแล้วก็คิด
ว่าเพราะว่าเรากำลังรอรถไฟฟ้าอยู่รถไฟฟ้า
ยังไม่มาก็คิดว่าใช่ถ้าเขาแซงคิ้ว
บอกดีไหม
เอาแบบคนไทยอ่ะไม่ชอบคิดแบบโกรธแต่ไม่พูด
หมิงก็ใครจะไม่ค่อยพูดใช่เขาไม่มีได้ก็
แบบพอรถไฟฟ้ามาถึงใช่ไหมคะวี๊ดรถไฟฟ้ามา
แล้วก็ประตูเปิดปิดๆคนเนี่ยก็ออกคนที่
อยู่ข้างในรถไฟฟ้าก็ออกเพราะคนออกหมด
เนี่ยเราแล้วก็เดินเข้าแล้วคนนี้ค่ะครับ
หมอเขาก็แซงคิวจริงๆเออเขาก็เดินเข้าไป
เลยพอประตูรถไฟฟ้าออกคนเดินออกหมดอาจคน
นี้นะคะคนต่างชาติอ่ะค่ะเขาก็เดินเข้าไป
เลยได้แบบไม่สนใจใคร
ทุกคนก็มองก็ไม่มีใครพูดผู้หญิงก็แบบคือ
ผู้หญิงนั่งคิดว่าโตมาสัก 3 นาทีเจ้าหน้า
ที่แล้วนะคะ
3 นาทีเดียวคิดใช่ไหมบอกดีไหมเนี่ยคิด
อยู่แล้วเพราะคิดว่าเขาจะต้องแซงคิวเรา
แน่ๆเอ่อก็คิดเสร็จแล้วก็เพราะเขาเดินมา
จะแซงคิวนะผู้หญิงก็เลยบอกว่าอยากเข้าแถว
ค่ะคิวพูด Hill ข้างหลัง
QR ทำไม่ได้ว่าพูดอะไรนะคะแต่ก็บอกว่า
เขาแถวประมาณว่าเข้าแถวข้างหลังอ่าแต่ว่า
คนนี้นี้นะคะคนนี้เขาโอเควันพรุ่งนี้เขา
ฟังแล้วก็ลูกสาวเค้าลูกสาวก็บอกมาๆ
เขาก็เลยเดินไปก็โอเคโอเคเนอะเออโอเคตาย
ก็คุณนิดเนี่ยจริงๆแล้วคุณเอ็กซ์ก็ถ้ามี
คนแซงคิว
คูนิกะคุณนี้ก็ปกติจะบอกแต่มันก็แล้วแต่
เหมือนกันว่าถ้าคุณนิดไม่รีบคุณในก็อาร์ต
เราถ้ามีคนนี้คนเดียวเนี่ยอยู่บ้างกับว่า
คนนี้กำลังจะซื้อของแล้ววมีคนเดินมาเลยมา
ตัดหน้าคุณอีกแบบเนี้ยถ้าคุณอีกไม่รีบคุณ
นี้ก็เอาปล่อยไปมันเป็นเรื่องเพลงเออแป๊บ
เดียวไม่เป็นไรแล้วก็ไม่ได้มีปัญหาแต่ห้า
คูณนิครีบหรือมีคนต่อแถวข้างหลังเหมือน
กันแล้วอยู่ดีๆคนนึงมาจากไม่รู้เนี่ยมา
ตัดคิวอันนั้นอะคุณนี้จะพูด
สายจะว่าอันนี้ผู้หญิงเคยเจอในเซเว่น
อีเลฟเว่นหลายๆครั้งนะคะเวลาแบบมีคนคือ
บางครั้งนะเรารอคิวที่เซเว่นน่ะมันมองไม่
เห็นไงว่ามีคิวหลายทางอะนิสัยทางใช่วัน
มองไม่เห็นน่ะซึ่งเหมือนกันถ้าผู้หญิงแบบ
เธอไม่เป็นไรถ้าเขาเดินมาแล้วเราก็เดินไป
เขาก็เดินมาพร้อมกันแล้วก็โอเคให้เขาก่อน
ก็ได้เพราะว่าแบบก็ไม่เป็นไรนิดหน่อยๆ
เอ่อใช่ได้นิดหน่อยหน่อยเนี่ยไม่มีปัญหา
แต่บางครั้งคุณนี้ก็จะพูดแต่ไม่พูดกับคน
นั้นตรงๆบางทีบางทีก็ถ้ามีคนมาแล้วเขาคุณ
นี่ก็พยายามคิดว่า x เขาอาจจะไม่รู้ว่า
คิวอยู่ตรงไหนคุณนี้ก็จะ
ก็อาจจะถ้าอยู่กับเพื่อนครูเน็กเกอร์พูด
เสียงดังกับเพื่อนว่าก็ขอต่อแถวตรงนี้
เนอะ
หมอไม่ได้บอกเขาตรงๆ
จังๆให้ได้อ๋อผู้หญิงเดินมาใช่ไหมกำลังจะ
แซงคิว
ใช่อยู่ดีก็นี้แถวอยู่ตรงนี้นะถูกต้อง
เนาะใช่ไหมเราต่อตรงนี้สึกแล้วเออ
กูเก๋ใส่
ใช่ก็ดีนะเพราะว่าคนไทยเนี่ยไม่ชอบพูดบอก
ตรงๆ
แต่มันเป็นคุณป้าหรืออายุเยอะเขาก็พูด
ด้วยแล้วเขาก็มันพูดยากอ่ะเพราะเขาก็ไม่
สนใจก็มีเหมือนกันมึงก็เลยจะทำยังไงการ
บางครั้งเขาก็จะแบบว่าเอ๊ยก็เขาแก่แล้ว
ไม่ใช่ไหมเขาแก่แล้วหมอเขายืนรอนานก็แบบ
เขาก็เหนื่อยใช่ไหมเรายังเด็กๆก็ขอไปก่อน
นะอะไร
ถึงคนแก่เขาจะขอเลยนะคะส่งวันครูนี้แหละ
เข้าคิวเป็นคนที่ 1 เขาจะเดินมาแบบขอป้า
ไปก่อนนะเออ
ใช้มีเหมือนกันคนนี้ก็โอเคนะคุณนี้ต้อง
ไม่ได้ซีเรียสไม่ได้กลัวถ้าเขาขอคุณนี่ก็
โอเคใช่แต่ว่าถ้าแบบเรามีคิวข้างหลังยาว
แล้วเขามาขอแซงคิวเราอันนี้ก็จะไม่ได้นะ
เพราะมีคิวมีคิวต่อข้างหลังคุณนิคเหมือน
เคยเคยดูวีดีโอเกี่ยวกับต่อคิวนี่แหละ
แล้วมันมีอยู่อันนึงมีคนเขาอยากจะตัดคิว
แซงคิวแต่เขาขอนะเขาขอคนที่อยู่ข้างหน้า
นะว่าขอแซงคิวได้ไหมแล้วทีแรกบอกว่าได้
แต่คนที่อยู่ข้างหลังทุกคนเนี่ยไม่รู้ว่า
ได้ไหมนะต้องไปถามเองแล้วก็
เออดีอี
กดีนะมันก็โอเคเพราะว่าถึงเราอยู่ข้าง
หน้าเราบอกเขาว่าได้แล้วถ้าคนนั้นมาอยู่
แซงคิวเนี่ยคนข้างหลังอาจจะด่าได้นะอาจจะ
พูดไม่ได้ทำไมปล่อยให้คนนี้มาอยู่ข้าง
หน้าเนี่ยรอตั้งนานแบบนี้ครับใช่น้ำเพราะ
ว่า
ตุ๊กแกนะแต่เธอถามคนข้างหลังด้วยว่าเขา
ให้ไหม
ต้องเป็นเทคนิควิธีนะมันก็เป็นเรื่องที่
ตลกดีว่าเออว่ะมันก็จิกอยู่เนาะเพราะมัน
ไม่ได้กับคนที่อยู่ข้างหน้าสุดคนเดียว
แล้วเพราะมันตอบยาวไม่มีเราโอเคและอีก 10
คนข้างหลังไม่โอเคมันก็ไม่หนึ่งใช่บ่าย
แล้วคุณก็เคยเจอแบบนี้แต่ว่าไม่แบบเป็น
เหมือน Immigration เป็นตม.กำลังจะเข้า
ประเทศครับตอนนั้นคิดว่าอเมริกานะคะแล้ว
เสร็จแล้วเราเนี่ยรอคิวอยู่แต่เราไม่ใช่
คนอเมริกานะเป็นคิวไม่ใช่คนอเมริกาแล้วก็
มีเจ้าหน้าที่เหมือนทำงานที่สนามบินเขาก็
เดินมาแล้วก็มีทหารทหารอเมริกาเขาก็บอก
ว่าให้เขาขอแสงคิวให้ทหารทหารไปก่อน
ปิด 9 ชุดแต่งคิวนะแต่เขาขอแค่ไงเขาขอเรา
ว่าโอเคคนนี้เป็นทหาร
ทหารอเมริกาให้ทหารไปก่อนครูหญิงรอรออีก 1
คิวให้คุณก็จะบอกไม่ได้ค่ะก็ไม่ได้หรอก็
ทหารจะบอกไม่ได้ค่ะโอเคงั้นก็บอกโอมก็ไม่
ต้องเข้าประเทศ
เออ
เรื่องการตกอยู่เนาะ
จ่ายค่ะเราก็ไม่รู้สึกอะไรที่ดีคนไทยเรา
ธรรมดาแบบชินแล้วกับการที่โดนแซงคิวแต่
เวลานักเรียนมาประเทศไทยและเรียนอาจจะแบบ
ตกใจนิดหน่อยนะคะว่าเฮ้ยทำไมประเทศไทยแซง
คิวบ่อยๆเออเฮ้ย
มันก็มี 8  *  * นี้คิดว่ามันน้อยลงแล้ว
นะตอนนี้น้อยนี่เมื่อก่อนเมื่อก่อนนี่ล่ะ
ใช่
มั้ยก่อนไม่มีคิวเลยเห้ยไม่มีคิวเลยเออ
ก็นั่นแหละครับเกี่ยวกับคิวในประเทศไทย
แต่ตอนถ่ายนักเรียนเคยเจอคนแซงคิวก็
คอมเม้นต์ได้นะคะแต่ว่าวีดีโอน
สายแต่ว่าวีดีโอนี้มันหมดเวลาแล้วเนาะ
เดี๋ยวและก็มาเจอกันใหม่ในวีดีโอหน้านะคะ
ไว้เจอกันใหม่สวัสดีครับสวัสดีค่ะ
ไม่ตายครับบ๊ายบายค่ะอ่ะ